welcome everybody to the h3 podcast
formerly live but now previously
recorded podcast welcome everybody today
we are sponsored by Ridge Wallace thank
you so much to Ridge wallets now is a
good time to go check out Teddy fresh
seafood there's something you like there
I'll support the show and today we are
joined by Mark rub EA that's right
who is a talented improvisational
musician comedian entertainer he is
going to be doing a live performance for
us slash interview after the break I am
super excited to meet with mark he is a
mega Talent
and actually Ian who is not with us
today brokered the whole thing but Ian
is like a mega fan of him but he's gonna
miss it
well we all are not and introduced us to
him no yeah yeah well I knew I mean I
knew of him but Ian was is the puppet
master yeah yeah actually in a in is
actually going to find love right now
can I say I think I can say that right I
mean it's a fantastic little tale ian is
on his way the batch the Bachelorette
who stole Ian's heart during our season
of The Bachelor is moving to LA to be
with Ian and Ian is flying to her right
now
to bring her back true love exists I
mean it became such an actual love story
it's such an actual love story that came
out of this stupid stupid segment it's
unbeliev at least one iteration of The
Bachelor worked out yeah what's what
what we thought was a tart it's time our
greatest failure turned out to be one of
our greatest successes and that's a
beautiful thing about life isn't it we
posted some new videos you may have seen
if you haven't seen them we posted two
new videos both about keemstar the DJ I
don't know what's DJ about him and he
calls himself DJ killer keemstar but is
he as he ever DJed
I've never seen him DJ fake news he does
weddings or something anyway we made
video called content nuke that we've
been working on for an entire month
hundreds of hours of editing and
research and I'm really happy with how
it came out
and the second one we actually was
working on I'm really happy with how it
worked out because we had done so much
work that the second video was like we
had completed a lot of the main pieces
of the second video by the time we
posted the first one so so worked really
great where we were we were able to
rapidly post the second video that was
still a really good high quality
polished video as well so that's a set
of videos I'm very happy with over on
h3h3 productions
you know chick-fil-a is open during this
pandemic and they are taking no chances
while you laughing at me because I have
ice in my mouth yes yeah I'm not very
professional not such a good can you see
him no chick-fil-a is taking no chances
okay check this [ __ ] out they actually
have their workers and little bubbles is
amazing but good on them right protect
your people
it looks custom-made
I love the laughter though you think
that's not good on them put your person
on a bubble something out there yeah I
would want to be in a bubble files were
contributing did you've gotta just be
taking so much [ __ ] all day though when
you're in a bubble but here's the thing
if the bubble is good for chick-fil-a
maybe we should all be walking around in
bubbles right maybe the bubbles is the
way of the future of society would you
to try and find them and yeah that's for
us here on the podcast well we're
thinking of going back to the podcast
studio soon so I wonder if we should all
be wearing these little chick-fil-a
bubbles yeah you should come down I
wonder what you would call this a human
a contained human environment bubble
chick-fil-a brand like I tell you though
since I watch this video I've been
wanting chick-fil-a I've been wanting to
filet so bad so I think that's gonna in
our future here soon
speaking of corona another brilliant
invention has come out of it so that you
can eat food through your your mask and
I have to be honest when I first saw
this from Twitter I thought this was
like like something terrible or you know
that website something like they just
post weird old content but this is real
and this is happening right now
everything is terrible everything is
terrible what did I say should my mouth
[ __ ] my tits anyway this is horrific
yeah this is perfect just take the thing
off and good thoughts guys you can't see
it I'm watching it just doesn't seem
that necessary
couldn't you just lift up your mask he
looks so pathetic he's still hitting the
thing when he's eating like the food
hits the you're gonna be such a nice
even in there sample video dangerous and
I mean there's a big gap where your
mouth is so I have to assume that this
is way less safe look always struggles
easy this is the best thing ever you
can't even fit a little bite of chicken
in there it's scary looking yeah and you
have to like work the mechanical hand I
mean guys so buy that - yeah please one
for each of us
and see if I can track it down I would
like to see a video on youtube of ten
hours of this you know Jeffrey star has
and then another coronavirus a themed
story Jeffrey started the cosmetic guru
and youtuber has come out with a new
palette called cremated bad timing
people are saying bad timing for a
cremated palate the point of course it's
bad timing because what do you do with a
disease-ridden corpse you cremate it and
I like how he's fading away to like damn
he's like God Thanos snaps like I'm not
wanting to put this makeup on just be
obliterated look at his face is just
melting away I'm kind of confused by
this busy beyond the bad timing
he actually had got a lot of [ __ ] he had
to make a statement which is kind of
it's funny because obviously probably
was working on it for a while for it to
come out now yeah I mean when we do like
a Teddy fresh drop the packaging and
everything it's a long process so I
totally get that I'm not offended by the
by the name I think it's funny people
are giving him [ __ ] but I am confused by
who the [ __ ] would want to look like a
zombie like I don't anything about
makeup but I am I know so serious makeup
artist I'm sure but I thought he loved
that makeup artists yeah but why is he
but he's doing like mass production of
cosmetics well isn't he trying to sell
to a mass audience he does so you wanna
buy the Frankenstein palette I'm just
saying he probably knows Monster pellet
sewing yeah oh that's yeah I really
would that one I sold out oh it is yeah
don't [ __ ] me in that again [ __ ] my dad
cremate my ass [ __ ] me and cremate me I
just okay I guess hold on let's see if
you're right
cremated eyes shadow palette no it's not
so Otis sold out 58 bucks oh man
do you buy one ela I wish we were
selling cosmetics I don't I wouldn't
even know what to do with it
cremate put it on your put it on my body
when I die of Corona I kind of think
it's a cool product you do oh okay well
I think I look at it from an artistic
point it's like when I buy a marker set
you know there's like a grayscale set
mm-hmm it's probably kind of like that
mmm I can see that it is like quirky and
cool you gotta have all the colors of
the rainbow
yeah but like his the photo shoot give
me something he's a zombie in the pool
he's trying to be like casual like he's
using it like casually it's not like I'm
doing I'm on a set no he's in his pool
looking like a damn undead zombie then D
selects it incidentally right or wrong
you're right then when you're right
you're right here's a video okay do you
have a calming table and this is where
you get cremated to much to take in here
Jeffrey star he's in a black room what's
his leather laws and a table female on
all fours it's a statue of a female all
fours and in a glass that's the table
everything is black and white too was
the whole room made for this palette it
certainly looks like it oh my god yeah
this guy's I'm just telling you do we
need to sell cosmetics I'll sell some
[ __ ] cremated cosmetics what palette
will you come up with
what pal should I sell I will sell the
spaghetti sauce face ballad make your
face what about all the fast food yeah
fast food inspired yeah jump on your
face am burger meat Brown right let's
see where the palette goes on the fast
Gordon probably brighter the cowboy that
looks like me from 90th day
this looks like me from the ninety the
fan slowed down Ethan get your words
together this guy looks like me and the
90's boy band video he literally is
dress k identical to me look at that tan
amazing no listen you guys really Slade
modeling when do I see the cremated and
this shade where he makes a statement
lipstick this crazy Lana's [ __ ] those
fingernails really gorgeous okay they're
not they're not putting the makeup on
how they what am I supposed to do when
they're not showing me the makeup which
we the video where he addresses the
backlash so he used the backlash to sell
it better that's a genius marker right
there oh my god yes you guys today one
of my best friends on the planet mister
lipstick naked you know what would have
been a better name in my opinion good um
something like film noir inspired maybe
no film new are
[Music]
cremated and it definitely know I like
cremated but pops you know what have
been better plague just play and death
you know be better been a corpse corpse
just corpse okay
just corpse that's been rotting for at
least a year right right exactly how the
hell she did this unreal cremated
grayscale makeup map I just don't get it
I'm sorry
where do you put this on exclude me from
this
I bet the like of the goth communities
you know maybe I'm just trying to
understand and I obviously don't know
anything about makeup but maybe it's
really hard to get that clean white
palette from makeup I don't know yeah I
mean when I did white man face I that my
makeup when I'm pretty easy but it's not
Jeffrey star quality so what kind of
backlash it again let's see Jeffery
start so you're gonna tell me Jeffery
stars releasing a palette called
cremated during a global pandemic where
thousands are dying please who are as PR
team also these shades are so nasty tell
me they aren't all dupes of themselves
oh the girls don't shade well if she
liked the palette would she have not
complained like what's the bigger issue
right just by the way we're just not a
fan that's a good point yeah the fact
that she doesn't like it discredits her
outrage what does dupes of themselves
mean
oh there ii thought up and there's only
one white so what am I supposed to do
with all this other crap it's just one
way and then a bunch of glitter like
when I got one of my
[ __ ] tin man I should buy one of
these into a review so it sold out
though dad sold out so anyway he says it
didn't come from a bad place and
obviously I of course I totally agree
that that would be crazy the reason he
didn't postpone the release is because
he has other pallets coming out this
year and there was just no place to put
it
just like the body's Jeffrey I'm kidding
I'm not I'm not angry hundred thousand
people almost dead by the way and
Jeffrey star is out here making cremated
guys at this point I want to give a huge
mother-loving thank you to Ridge Wallace
which is quickly becoming what can only
be described as the greatest most
efficient wallet around you slide your
card in you keep your cash right here
your money clip it's slick
it's modern it's tight and it's just
right comes with this little screw it's
the anti Costanza wallet for those of
you who know what I'm talking about this
is a light sleek industrial wallet it
doesn't fold awkwardly bulge in your
back pocket and it has seriously changed
my whole pocket situation it is designed
to easily fit into any of your pockets
and most people who are still using
walls designed in the 90s carrying
around all receipts
gift cards hotel keys and an unorganized
mess the Costanza wallet is now a thing
of the past so here's the deal it holds
up to 12 cards plus it has room for cash
there are over 30 colors and styles
including carbon fiber and burnt
titanium I personally really do love it
but don't take my word for it they've
got 30,000 five-star reviews the durable
material means each wallet has a
lifetime warranty you could buy this one
wallet and carry it for life
Brij wallet the rich team is so
confident that you'll like it they'll
let you test drive it for 45 days you
could send it back for a full refund if
you don't love it oh that's awesome
so you got nothing to lose guys head on
over to rage calm slash h3 use the code
h3 and get 10% off today with free
worldwide shipping and returns by going
to Ridge comm slash h3 and using code h3
this Ridge wallet is going to change the
game I got to tell you I hate the
Costanza wallet I hate having [ __ ]
jiggle around my pocket but this is like
I love it Ridge wall thank you guys
alright and Joe Rogan making big moves
actually that affects all of us really
in the podcasting space Joe Rogan has
signed an exclusive deal with Spotify
there's a lot of interesting facets here
one being that he's moving his video
portion of his podcast to Spotify which
means the videos are going on Spotify
now that doesn't exist right now does it
know YouTube should be scared
yeah dude Spotify is such a huge beloved
platform that videos going up there
could could really YouTube could be
could be facing a crisis here
for sure I wonder how they feel about it
and if there was any negotiation at all
with YouTube - like dude the money he
came on YouTube but I feel like they
made a big I mean it's a big loss for
you - well I don't think YouTube would
have shut out the kind of money they say
so they reported that it was at least a
hundred million dollars now I've heard
from people I've heard from people that
that that maybe ripped a good source for
this that it was well over a hundred
million I've heard the number as high as
five hundred million
yeah that's great but is it crazy
because didn't when they announced that
they signed him exclusively the market
cap for Spotify
increased by 1.7 billion look at that
spike in their stock on the announcement
that they had signed Joe Rogan it they
got 1.7 billion dollars of new value
that's holy crap
I'm not there though I think a lot of
that was probably the fact that it came
along with this announcement about that
they're they're entering video like some
is for sure that Joe Rogan is like kind
of the lead pilot guy that they're
bringing in to spearhead that but just
the the fact alone like you said that
they're they're going in on on YouTube
space is a huge deal yeah it is gonna be
really interesting to see what happens
and you know I don't think YouTube would
have put out that kind of my and and and
well Spotify is a paid service so they
have a lot more they have a lot more to
gain by bringing Joe Rogan over it
reminds me a lot of like once Howard
Stern what's a serious they gave Howard
certain like ungodly hundreds of
millions of dollars you know but but
ultimately it was it was a totally worth
it for them so this is really really
interesting his podcast is now on
Spotify and it will be going exclusively
by the end of the year including video
he says it will remain free and will be
exactly the same show it's just a
licensing deal
so Spotify won't have any creative
control over the show they just want me
to continue doing it the way that I'm
doing it now
yeah I wonder if thinking buy keep
buying up such a big move I have to say
that I'm so I have to say I'm so
impressed by Joe Rogan's foresight
because he intentionally kept his show
off Spotify for all this time now our
shows on Spotify and I really like it
there we got a lot of audience there so
it's really good for us but I guess his
shows so big that you know whatever
amount of audience he gets is negligible
there but the foresight to not go on
there for years was so genius I will
never I wouldn't have thought of that
he's playing 3d chess with and there
go it's uh it really is well-deserved
- I mean what he's done with the podcast
is just insane
you guys were talking about um his
downloads
I don't you say I was surprised by the
number they mentioned that somewhere
briefly over his YouTube channels
enormous to eight and a half million
subscribers and a musician would need
yeah I don't see it maybe you can find
it I know a lot of his fans are not
happy about it though they see it as
selling out and I don't know actually to
do the show better because it gets so
difficult on YouTube to do the show yeah
we experience it all the time I mean
money aside there's issues of this new
issue that's new tormenting everybody is
the block the block worldwide so money
aside okay you have companies blocking
your video because it has content they
have it's like go ahead and claim it I
don't give a [ __ ] but they block it so I
think it's time for some healthy
competition you know in this space and I
personally think it will only help it
will help everybody ultimately last year
the podcast was downloaded 190 million
times per month 100 million times per
month 190 190 almost 200 million million
well that's probably why he had so
little loyalty to YouTube anyways I mean
that he gets a small fraction of that
from YouTube's vast majority of that is
still in audio downloads you know so
what does he really care about YouTube
in the grand scheme of things I wonder
if we're gonna get more audience on
Spotify now though cuz they're all these
people are gonna go to Spotify to listen
to Joe right in this article they say
they quote someone and he's saying Joe
Rogan just got paid the equivalent value
of over 26 billion streams
for a podcast license 26 billion streams
mm-hmm well they're saying it I think
that's assuming that hundred million
dollar paycheck number how many streams
you would need to get to a musician
would need to generate twenty three
billion streams on Spotify to earn what
they're paying Joe Rogan for the rights
but because any one stream that much
because I know like post alone like his
big hits are doing like a billion
streams but that means yeah you see he's
probably done like five billion or
something that's a long yeah I don't I
don't know if anybody has
what did you say twenty one bill 93
billion streams but that's that's just
what they paid him to move it over I
also wonder if he's gonna be able to put
ads on it if they're gonna control that
ads how that's gonna work I'm very
curious about this whole situation
but congratulate Joe on a on a bounty
well deserved and I'm very curious about
how that shakes up the landscape you
know speaking of failed tech initiatives
on the other side of the coin creepy
have you guys heard of creepy
these guys spent 400 to 500 million
dollars advertising and I've never heard
of it this has got to be one of the
biggest epic fails in modern day tech
startups it stay is short for quick bite
and the premise is that it's Netflix for
its mobile only and they making 10
minute long content productions and
that's really high high-end production
with famous actors and comedians and all
this [ __ ] so they spent like here they
spent I think like a billion dollars or
more for chrissake 1.75 billion dollars
they raised and it's just a total flop
and I mean I wish they would have
consulted me first because I could have
told them straight up that this idea was
awful I don't want to watch I don't want
to pay money to watch 10 minute videos
on my phone yeah
I I mean that content is supposed to be
free people expect that kind of content
to be free right and how much is it it's
kind of expensive to $8 a month man [ __ ]
off so this guy this is even better he's
blaming the rocky launch on get this
coronavirus he says he says the company
courted a list talent like Steven
Spielberg Jennifer Lopez and raised over
1.75 billion in funding qui B was
ultimately meant to be a service for
users on the go which is a selling point
that disappeared after coronavirus
forced people to stay inside I'm sorry
if you're making a media company that
that when people have way more free time
on their hands and they usually do is up
is a strike against you then your [ __ ]
sucks like man I bought all this time on
my hands I definitely don't want to
watch qui be there's a way better [ __ ]
than that he says it's not really
unexpected that query has a rough start
being a mobile only streaming service
was all they are always a risky bet I
mean most services are multi-platform
and consumers have made it clear they
don't want to be a dedicated and how
they watch entertainment so why did you
do it then this is the guy who made it
the corona virus pandemic has only
exacerbated the underlying issues that
cui B has as a service yeah there's
actually we actually have some footage
from a qui be original here you won't
take alfredo poor boys not feeling well
so this was um here we have some of
their great the Golden Arm show my god
Dan you want to set this up oh just as
far as that clip yeah so actually I
think it's better if people just see it
cold and then I can give a little bit of
context a position but I think it's
actually so this is an Emmy winner
Rachel Brosnan Brosnahan plays a woman
obsessed with her Golden Arm now this
isn't a comedy because I saw this Mel's
like oh it's just it's like a weird
zany comedy no really
[Music]
them course we'll check maybe already no
you can't be serious I still look it up
I mean this is a this is a famous folk
nobody needs a job I can't take no but
their acronym it's a comedy
they're like overacting and stuff like
this is a continual look at the badass
thing that's not serious I refuse to
believe I don't believe it I frankly
don't believe it someone said its threat
level midnight if it is oh that was
Chrissy Teigen famous Chrissy Teigen
ladies and gentlemen I don't believe
that that's not a comedy and I will
never I mean I'm gonna have to download
qui bein walk well so okay so what I
will give you is that it is part of a
project from Sam Raimi it's a horror
anthology thing that he did for qui be
you know kind of like or what was that
show that was an info American Horror
Story right where it's like each one is
kind of its own little sub story or
maybe a Twilight Zone is a good way to
think about it or black mirror or
something like that so each one is like
its own little thing and you know this
is Sam Raimi has always been a little
like tongue in cheek with it's not like
Evil Dead and and stuff like that he's a
little goofy but still I mean this
it is supposed to be scary no Meg
Whitman said our target audience at
quippy is 25 to 35 years old see that's
already bad you're a mobile device look
at dude your audience should be ticked
off everyone yeah what better way to get
content for that target demo than hiring
our target demo
I love Millennials and Gen Z errs
enthusiasm and can-do attitude I mean
it's like a condescending parent does
that just mean they just hired cheap
they work very hard and they want to do
great things and I think they love that
they can get more responsibility at a
start-up like qui B that sounds so bad
so they started with 2 billion in the
bank and over 200 employees not exactly
this tech startup that you would think
of also I'm noticing in this article
that they quote the founder and he says
he's unhappy with the company's results
he's miserable
yeah but then the CEO which is a
different person is saying she says that
she thinks it's it's doing pretty okay
yes she's spinning it he's like [ __ ]
this I just wish a billion dollars yeah
they go the CEO goes I think you'll see
nice slow steady growth no like I'm
curious and I'm not even gonna buy it
and I'm rich and I'm frankly I'm rich
too I'm not it's like not worth the
effort to download their stupid app and
don't worry about canceling I'd rather
open YouTube it's what you guys think of
the name just that's awful it's awful
Inc we beat everything about it's awful
I'm surprised this thing made it to
light other news raging Hollywood Hills
house party ends when a man shoots
himself in the groin that's it okay just
a headline large gatherings are still
prohibited in Los Angeles but that
didn't stop a raging house party
Saturday night in the Hollywood Hills
that ended when police say a man
himself in the penis now that's a
[ __ ] rager
[Laughter]
when they responded they found that more
than a hundred people were gathered at
the short-term rental property that
appeared to be reserved for the occasion
it's a nice house you can see pictures
of it I just like to imagine 100 people
gather around this one do it do it do it
and then finally ending ah wait real
quick in that article did you say that
when when the paramedics showed up there
were still hundreds of people gathered
there yes for a dude had shot himself in
the dick I would have bounced at that
point nah dude you don't know how to
party bro this is a good runner virus
party bike when people start shooting
their own dicks off is usually when I
dip from a party yeah you win evade the
scene on down why the party climaxed at
that point it's all done where do you go
from there
shoot the tits off Lori Loughlin
and Massimo Julia Jian Li Li Jian newly
so many times that we still don't know
how to say anyway these are the parents
during the college admissions scandal
that paid half a million bucks so
they're dumbass Oh their daughter was a
youtuber and they faked that she was
like on the ski on the on the RO team
yes you can get into USC and they were
trying to fight it unlike all their
parents who are like all the other
parents were like yes we [ __ ] up this
is humiliating we take the plea deal
whatever I plead guilty but these two
geniuses wanted to fight it in court and
the government is just piling on charges
being like okay okay you don't want to
take the plea deal here's another charge
they were looking at they were looking
at like 40 years in prison or some [ __ ]
if they lost you know so the government
laid
heavy enough that they were like alright
so the new sentence this is the plea
deal Laurie has agreed to two months in
prison and a $250,000 fine and two years
of probation she also has to perform 250
hours of community service which
hopefully means her and orange jumpsuit
on the side of the but now with
coronavirus that just means she gets to
do that at home you're right
that's absolutely right so she basically
was house arrest
good well they're definitely dragged
forever yeah and then her husband is
going to do five months in prison and
two hundred and fifty thousand dollars
of fine and 250 hours of community
service 250 hours that's quite a bit I
mean that's that's like eight hours
what's 250 divided by 8 they probably
didn't do 8 hours like what do you
imagine it's probably like a three hour
shift right or four hours so what's 250
divided by 4 we're talking about 4 when
people have to do the community service
on the side of the road or whatever yeah
it's it's a full day Oh second hours
I've known a few people that I've had to
do community service and an you look up
their whole day ok so what's what's a
250 divided by 8 I'm not smart enough to
do that in my head 31 days 31 and a
quarter so that's a straight month of
yeah it's pretty good you might you
might do like a half it's probably over
2 months or 3 something like that and
then it said he's and then he's going to
jail for 5 months huh yeah but as he'll
pointed out they won't put him there
because of the virus yeah they'll be
under house arrest
they had vowed to fight the charges as
for why the charge change of heart they
were facing multiple felonies the feds
kept adding charges the longer they
resisted and a convicted on all counts
could have served more than 40 years
yeah [ __ ] that damn yeah you take the
deal at that point oh yeah oh and then
another one Kendall gentle a kendall
Jenner agrees to cough up $90,000 over
fire festival promo because she was one
of the models that was promoting the
[ __ ] and what's actually interesting
this is a lesson for all you kids in
business she got paid 275 thousand so
she's still walking away with a cool and
clean one she's got a lot of money still
on eighty-five thousand pretty well yeah
so that's that's a lesson for you when
deciding if to break the law just think
that if you get fine just make more
money than if what the fine is for
that's how pharmaceutical companies
think about everything
they're like damn we put so okay this
medicine killed like a thousand babies
but we did make a billion dollars the
FDA is gonna charge us 250 million so
we're still gonna make 750 thousand the
babies is just collateral million but
the point stands yes what it's a
thousand instead of a million well
million babies No did you say million
babies you just no you said go ahead and
correct me you uh you meant to say 750
million you said 750 thousand millions
but why do you say million babies died I
did not start well you put that image no
babies were harmed in the making this
podcast oh yeah that's my favorite rule
the fire that's the fire fraud ja rule
goes it's not fraud it's just false
advertising right you [ __ ] idiot
okay let's talk with mark Ruby a we've
got him on zoom we are gonna ask him
some questions we are gonna get some
live performers I am super excited to
jam with our boy mark welcome back
everybody we are here with Mark Ruby a
did I say your name right
you didn't and you know what that's okay
wait say it for me it's close it's rub
rub rub ei
France very French and yeah I've heard
every permutation it's okay and are you
uh are you a French man have you been
are you from France oh yeah I'm a little
French boy I'm a half French boy
my dad's French and or was French and my
mom's American well mark if you don't
know is an improvisational musician
extraordinaire mega talent [ __ ] and
correct me if I'm wrong here sprung from
the bowels of Reddit the first time I
remember seeing you I don't know if
that's if that sounds uh Ben that's
pretty accurate
yeah reddit was really helpful in the
beginning for sure I think I could say
that I also sprang from the bowels of
Reddit but the thing that I would the
first time I saw you was on this strange
reddit Live tool where I don't know if
they still have it where whoever has the
most viewers is on the top and everyone
watches and that was yeah right yeah so
we were you already kind of somewhat
reddit famous before the public asset
access thing or was that part of your
eyes um I mean I guess I don't know to a
degree you know it's like every once in
a while I would upload some [ __ ] and
then read it you know the videos
subreddit would would share it and just
depending on the video it would do I it
would do well or it would do very poorly
but you know reddit is fickle like that
it's like the timing has to be right the
title has to be right and then the video
needs to be it's like within the first
like ten seconds you need to be
interested or else people will just [ __ ]
all over it so it was it took it took a
while well rent is like boot camp for a
content creation but it is funny
sometimes when I was coming up you post
a video you could post the video on
reddit and one day you will get
downloaded into oblivion
you'll post the same video the same
title same everything the next day and
it will go to the front page you would
place a song you want me to make you a
little something what are we what's on
our minds how do you how does your
musical creation work you just kind of
go off you riff do you have make music I
know your bicycle I make it from scratch
I've got my little my little looper
right here and my little keyboard and
drum pads right here I don't know if you
can see that but you might be able to
once we switch over and yeah I just
start selecting sounds and you know like
a drum sound and then I'll put some
shakers on there and a little keyboard a
little bass and then they'll all just
layer up and then I just make some [ __ ]
up over it
this is your medium of choice but I know
you were classically trained is that
right yeah originally when I was when I
was a tiny tiny little child I started
taking piano lessons and and then I
basically classically until I was maybe
15 and then I stopped and taught myself
sort of improvisational jazz so
classical I don't know there's a
foundation for music theory but I don't
I don't I couldn't I couldn't play a
piece of music off of you know off of a
sheet interesting huh I'm just saying
either yeah I was watching some of your
live performances oh and it's it looks
like it would be so scary because it's
just all on the spot and you get you
even get naked and then not make it like
I do I do it's the live shows are the
same where I'll like I have no plan like
if you've ever seen Reggie Watts yeah
you know it's like that's it's the same
idea where I walk out on stage with no
plan no setlist nothing prepared and
then just see what happens you know and
just see what the [ __ ] happens and
sometimes it's good sometimes it's a
little less good but hopefully it's like
you know there's a baseline of
entertainment there and are do you find
it terrifying
berating and walking out there without
any plan any set I mean how do you how
how kind of have you prepared for a show
I guess - uh it's definitely both it's
for sure terrifying and very liberating
and it's also plays to my strengths
because I'm like just a super impatient
person I don't like planning for shin
practicing this thing and I don't like
doing all of that so if I can it's a
pretty amazing job I just walk out there
and like do my thing for an hour and
yeah man I don't know I I don't really
prepare much I sort of you know all like
drink a little water I'll have a beer
and I'll just sort of stand back there
and like jump up and down and you know
psych myself up a little bit and and
then off we go
you just got to get out there and [ __ ]
on it the energy levels are insane and
actually I want to watch this one video
if I may and you can't see it but it's
you I'll play for the audience now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so tough about the setting because it
looks like you're just a sandwich strong
and these people don't know who you are
right so you're kind of just like
blowing this place up the energy is
insane everybody is like what is going
on tell me about this show dude that
that was that like that was I would say
I think two years ago when I was
starting in Dallas that's where I'm from
originally I live in New York now but
when I was in Dallas I got I sort of
managed to finagle these like three
weekly residences at bars and
restaurants where like they they
especially that place that's brain dead
brewing in Dallas and they would pay me
to come in at like 1:00 p.m. to their
lunch crowd who doesn't give a [ __ ] that
has no clue who I am and they would just
let me do us like a three-hour set
justify but it seems the reception is
good I mean people are like holy [ __ ]
you know yeah that that was a few I
think that was maybe like towards the
end when I had started to establish a
small following so people started like
coming to the restaurant in the
afternoons and [ __ ] you know but at the
beginning it's like there's videos I
live streamed all those performances and
like it's just like ten people in the
restaurant looking up from their [ __ ]
bologna like oh this is I love all these
performances from the from what I mean
it looks like a sandwich shop I don't
know bar yeah it's like a brew pub a
brew pub so with that being said would
you like to play play some music
play a CD make some [ __ ] up I thought
maybe doing something for like h3 might
be fun I love it make it make a little
something for h3 I don't know maybe
it'll suck but like we should give it a
shot I'd love to hear that all right
yeah we're gonna do that
[Music]
[Music]
good get that in there
[Music]
get in on the microphone everybody sit
the [ __ ] down yo it's time for the
podcast [ __ ] be thinning Neil and Dan
and Zach and me and baby you're coming
through little
[Music]
[Music]
that was to a chorus
[Music]
[Music]
some deep cuts dude I liked it good I
even the are Kelly do you have your
passports Wow
fantastic did you get your shots tell me
about your setup here let's see what you
got here you got that the audio with all
the fat buttons tell me about these huge
buttons I heard you got to check these
big buttons out this is a buss RC 505
it's got five little channels excuse me
where you can register all of the tracks
all of my little looping tracks like the
pianos right here I muted I muted it so
you can't hear but anyway there's five
channels that you can load in sounds and
like overdub sounds on so that's how you
do the harmonies and that's you know and
then there's little knobs for you to
[ __ ] with stuff and filters for your
voice and then these are my drum pads
got my little drum pads here there's 16
of them and you can assign them all to
play you know whatever sample you want
them to play and then I've got 49
velocity sensitive keys here that are
just silky and and and light to the
touch
gave me some give me some velocity
examples show me show me show me the how
the feather and weight differences or
tell you let me show you exactly how
that works I'm gonna now mute my voice
here and go back to the stream so you
can hear fantastic so now that we're
back velocity of light velocity is gonna
be okay heavy Wow very very
[Music]
so you know you got its expression it
allows you to be soft or heavy with it
to get you know to get to get thicker
light with it so would you be open to
I'm gonna I'm gonna throw you a idea
keemstar song with both light and
sensitive touch let's say like let's say
like this how about this team start
chapter 1 comp the nuke goes off that's
obviously ice high velocity the nuclear
fallout is more of a feather touch still
deadly though Oh baby okay
we're gonna hit a little keemstar trying
to think about oh yeah yeah okay alright
keemstar team stars a giant piece of
[ __ ] yo baby said came stars a giant
piece of [ __ ] goddamn it baby became
stars a giant piece of [ __ ] goddamn it
baby
[Music]
I can't do a light touch there's no
light touch when it comes to keen I'm
getting old [ __ ] I'm kidding me this is
star walking around a juice child unique
juice child
team stars a damn douche [ __ ] juice the
damn couch [ __ ] douche [ __ ] team
stars a [ __ ] damn douche [ __ ]
[Music]
relentlessly
I don't know how is that I was fantastic
what big boys are talking I was a head
bobbing the whole time
I couldn't go light on it I really
couldn't do keemstar with a light no I
totally understand there's no light
touch there yeah you I assume it takes
some time to master the arts of
improvisational music tell me about your
process of getting to become the music
ninja that you are today like wonder how
do I mean how even doing so glad yes
yeah it it I mean I don't know dude it
took it took a while for sure but
basically I mean I've just been playing
piano since I was a kid and also acting
since I was a kid and this show is like
it's a marriage of those two things you
know it's it's just sort of an absurd
completely ridiculous journey into
whatever the [ __ ] I feel like doing that
day and I it's it comes I mean I've been
basically trying to make music for the
last 13 or 14 years I guess
very unsuccessfully mmm it's deeply
unsuccessfully and and then I found this
little loop station and was still very
unsuccessful for a number of years and
then I lost a job and that's when I
decided to try and like book gigs in
Dallas and that's when I sort of you
know you have to take it seriously if
you're not right willing to take it
seriously it probably won't take you
seriously you know and at what point was
there a moment where you're like oh [ __ ]
this is actually working uh I think it
happened fairly quickly like once I was
able to get those few gigs in Dallas I
well I think there were two different
stages it's like
they're the the gigs in Dallas were
paying my rent so that already was
amazing yeah
amazing to me that I thought that was
that happening and and then when I moved
to New York I had to sort of start from
scratch again I had a small following on
YouTube maybe like ten thousand
subscribers and and and then a couple
months into being in New York people
started sharing the stuff around on
Facebook of all places it's my largest
platform believe it or not wow I did not
know that tell me about your Facebook
page what's that tell me about your
Facebook page because I don't I don't
spend any time on Facebook these days so
I mean I don't either but apparently a
lot of people do yeah so wait how many
followers on Facebook how many views to
your videos get there I have over a
million on Facebook and they get I mean
it depends on the video but there's
there's plenty with 1015 million views
that's fantastic to find an audience on
Facebook thanks dude I mean I didn't
plan it at all I just I just sort of
started uploading my [ __ ] natively to
like my you know my page and at some
point in their like late 2018 I noticed
that like some of these videos that I
had made like a year ago were all of the
sudden like hitting I mean wow wow I had
like 10,000 likes on my page and within
a week it was like fifty a hundred
thousand fifty thousand and the Zach
smiled upon you wow you guys decided to
light up sunshine hey why don't we do a
song about Mark Zuckerberg that seems
like a fun topic that's a great idea why
don't we say our prayer to Mark
Zuckerberg for your Facebook page a
prayer for Mark Zuckerberg yeah that
sounds awesome
our internet our internet father he have
course and resident cyborg right spotty
idea of doing like hey Shelley yes sir
hey could you uh tell me just real
but could you check outside and just let
me know if we out here yes give me just
a second sir hey Jim what's up chilly
just that boss wants to know if we're
out here yes we are sir yes we out here
we fully out here thank you so much
Shelley I appreciate that okay
Mark Zuckerberg we are out here let's do
a little something a little something
for sweet sucker
oh sweet sucky look really weird oh yeah
you got what the [ __ ] is going on with
your sweet baby Ray's alright
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Mark Zuckerberg born mark XKE 12-unit be
born to wealthy parents mark never knew
pain Harvard Graduate coding his little
heart out what one day oh yes
mark knew he had to make something
happen before you knew it
mark was in control of an empire
and it was at that point when all suck
was sitting on top of the world sitting
pretty baby
that he said
finally my plans are complete I have the
entire world logged categorized
I can finally use them so I will
[Music]
[Music]
that's we're gonna do
[Music]
[Music]
yeah babies sucking finally you can take
over the world control us and make us do
his bidding kill everybody
this is suck now that you're logged into
your Facebook account you can kill each
other
everyone kill each other immediately
mark what has happening what's happening
to me I must kill I must kill thank you
lord Zuckerberg thank you killing people
here I go no problem luck I'll do what
you want coffee how much cream yo I got
you [ __ ] I'm doing it for you you roll
my mind my heart my spine tell me what
to do I'll be there for you baby don't
you know it sucking sucked
hmm Wow so we'll play it out there a
ballad Hartsook I think you would be
proud of that and frankly I hope you
haven't given him any ideas either you
have a beautiful you have a it an
absolutely beautiful singing voice yeah
Oh tremendous voice I want to tell you I
appreciate that
that's it didn't used to be as decent it
took a while that was that was one of
the things that I never really worked on
much until I started like getting on
stage and and doing that you know but do
you take singing lessons or is that all
in just from performing it's all
performing all performing you just you
know it's like you after your but you
know I probably I don't know I've
probably played well over two to three
hundred shows at this point and you just
have to you just have to get you have to
like make it happen and especially once
you start playing bigger venues with
bigger you know crowds that are
expecting bigger you know better music
you you have to step it up and I don't
know yeah I just just vocal warm-ups and
[ __ ] that helps but yeah man you know
the more you do something the the better
you get at it hopefully so do you ever
feel restricted by the medium you've
chosen I know that I I'm just curious
because you you're not playing with
other people I'm curious how could you
like if you wanted to put out an album
of music for example like how would you
approach that I'm curious if you have
any interest in branching out into other
types of music or if you are just uh if
you're just gonna you know if this is
your your medium of choice no yeah it's
definitely I mean I do feel constrained
a little bit like restricted a little
bit I guess by just the nature of this
which is that I have five channels I
have to do it my sits just it's it is
very contained it's doesn't
you can be creative but you have to be
creative within the parameters of this
you know and so it yeah it definitely
it's not something I want to do forever
I think this is I love playing the show
I think it's a ton of fun I I guess I
would like to do it on and off for as
long as I can but it's a very high
energy show yeah there's a lot it's just
a lot of [ __ ] energy dude I'm like
I'm starting to get older you know so
let me tell you when you put when you
when you put up your giant buttons when
you hang those up what's next for mark
next on the table there's a few things I
want to I want to stretch my my arms
more broadly into entertainment at large
very like I'm working on a show that I
really can't say more about but that I'm
very excited about and then I would love
to make an album just like you said I'd
love to pose produce a piece of work get
in a studio with a band and make it and
then possibly tour it and then I think
like the dream button at the end of all
the buttons is is probably a man dude I
would [ __ ] love to be a late-night
host so really really so much you think
it can work
yes you got the energy multi-talent you
can do it all yeah it's a vibe out here
it's just a giant vibe out here you guys
it's funny because I on the other hand I
have always looked at late-night host
and while I admire what they do I'm like
wow I would [ __ ] hate that job you
know what I mean it's relentless
why why it's like every day night you
have to go and [ __ ] do it and it's
like it's just like it just seems like a
hammer and you could tell like all these
guys who've been in the game
years it's just like all everything it's
like true there's some people I'm like a
huge I'm a pretty big fan of late night
like Conan in particular I love
Letterman and Conan but yeah you can see
there's like stretches of their lives
where they clearly do not want to be oh
yeah [ __ ] who are you yeah
why am I supposed to give a [ __ ] about
okay you know a really good purpose I
feel like I love that I can just put it
on every night even if that episode is
[ __ ] made that like thing that I can put
on every night totally I agree
it's a beautiful tradition and I don't
know if I would want to do it Network
but but I you know you can I think the
world is wide enough now that you can
just do whatever the [ __ ] you want
basically tell me I know you are going
on tour soon despite the you found a way
to tour in the middle of a pandemic tell
me about that yes I'm really [ __ ]
excited about that we did like I think
about a month ago my my good people my
good agent people called me and they
were like yo a friend of ours in Germany
a client of his just did a show at a
drive-in movie theater and it did very
well what do you think I was like shut
that hot mouth and let's do this
immediately go go and the dude they put
together a tour in like under a week and
a half like a tour it's unsafe
how do people have that how does it work
oh okay so the way it works yes so I
mean they basically had to find drive-in
movie theaters first of all that's a
small market you know I mean like the
amount of drive-in movie theaters in the
United States is not as huge as it was
in 1952
and and then furthermore you need to
find drive-in movie theaters that are
willing to take a risk and put on like a
live show which thins the bunch out even
more so you know I don't know how the
[ __ ] they did it but they worked with
this production company called hotbox
and now we have I believe ten dates
I think I'm playing ten or eleven dates
across the u.s. drive-in movie theaters
you're gonna pull your ass up whatever
you do in your car is your business you
don't give a [ __ ] about that just pull
on up don't leave the car you know we're
gonna regulate bathroom breaks and [ __ ]
but all the social distances stuff is
going to be pretty heavily regulated you
can only open your window a certain
amount I'll be broadcasting to you via
FM radio I'll be there playing I'm gonna
run my little ass around the cars it's
gonna be dude it's gonna be so [ __ ]
dope so yes so there'll be a stage and
then people will be listening to you on
the radio that's right yes so they're
gonna be like facing the screen you know
like the drive-in screen is there like
old museum relics now they're doing
great business like now they're sold out
every night yes yeah it is only game in
town what else could you do and so if
people want to get tickets where do
where do the people good people of
America find tickets to these shows you
know that's just such a fantastic
question eat them and let me tell you
it's WWWE won a hot box com
I want to spell the casual way waa and
na I wanna hog box.com
we're gonna find your suite tickets
there I'm gonna pick them up and what is
a hot mom doing yeah but it's a hot box
and white oh you know what hot box I
mean just when you smoke weed in a small
room okay is that what your box it's
when you fill a car with weed
I'm not use the URL I wish I did because
I
it was pretty funny but that's not that
wasn't my doing who would put your tour
on I wanna hotbox calm who did such a
thing don't like it you don't think it's
good no it's great but like I mean just
is a big decision to make for you I
agree you know it is I agree I guess I
probably I probably could have put it on
my website somehow but I'm I'm pretty
lazy and also I love that URL dude yes
fantastic I would buy it I want that I
mean I would I would just take that for
yourself if it's Bob I want a hot box
and calm spelled colloquially waa nna of
course mark why don't we play it one
more song to play them off if that's
okay with you I love it let's do um
the theme do we have a theme covet 19
hit me with something covet 19 is pretty
good pretty I want to do maybe over
kovat yeah what do we got what's good
what's how about dumb hmm does the
peanut does anyone have anything
tickling there uh anybody at OSHA's hit
me oh why don't we do something based
off of one of our lead stories today
about how about cremation or what was
the other one cremation Jesus dance
cremation oh yeah I love it we're doing
cremation inspired my cremation okay
cremation I've switched why do you just
have them do it on the Holocaust while
we're at it I'm talking about beep you
know what I'm talking about
yeah Bing boom cremate ashes ashes now
ashes in the urn urn with the ashes in
our
[Music]
it's such a sad day it's such a sad day
and may we all please mourn the passing
of our dearly beloved may we all please
just more in every one Jim I need you to
mourn mourn okay everyone more in the
passing and we're all here mourning gosh
inches
thank you so much and thank you everyone
for coming to the service it's really
really just so lovely having you all
right
Anne do you want to take the urn yeah do
you guys need it for anything
no it's all yours we know we know she
would have loved you to have it you guys
thank you so much it's really sweet yeah
all right you take care all right yeah
sounds good sounds good oh just gonna
take this earning is anyone looking at
me no one's looking at me
oh hey Jim Bob I just just wanted to
make sure everything was everything's
fine everything's fine just celebrating
her life in her life and doing that
great great okay have a good one all
right
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Wow
leave it to mark to make cremation a
topic of joy and pleasure incredible I I
don't know if that has anything to do it
all with oh not everything what the news
item is but there you have it
I was wonderful mark I want to thank you
so much it was a joy it was a pleasure
to share your musical challenge with us
to learn a little bit about you the
people but they want to join you at
these uh Drive Drive in performance
driving live shows man I want a hotbox
calm it's kind of hard to forget because
the play so interesting place so head on
over to I won a hot box calm catch him
doing a live show there's nothing else
to do for Christ's sake during this time
go see mark I mean it's gonna be a
fantastic show you guys got a little
taste of what he's got up his sleeve
here today YouTube I have to say and the
whole gang I love you guys so so much
you've brought me an enormous amount of
joy over the years you know how dope you
are and you guys are the [ __ ] you guys
are the shits Thank You Man thank you so
much I really appreciate that you're
such a talent I just can't even believe
witnessing the pleasure is mutual it's
me it's a little mutual masturbation
yes frauding I believe they call that
well that's what we've all done here
well y-yeah Zak you watched did you
enjoy it
I I look good so we've got YouTube we've
got I want a hot box we've got what tell
me about your year you to Bismarck
rub a rub I'm sorry dude you
Robbie hey baby I get I have like a
phobia that once I say a name wrong I
get so embarrassed that I never want to
say it you should absolutely an absurd
name but so what your YouTube is uh
Rubby a your twitter is mark reveille a
yeah my everything is mark rubble yay
mark Rubbia all across the board mark
gruba com youtube.com slash mark Rubby a
mark rebbe a LinkedIn you got a strong
network that me right on there all right
mark thank you so much we appreciate you
we bless you we wish you all the best in
this life and the next one as well
hopefully the next one comes later
like what thank you for having me guys
all right god bless you bye
all right guys thank you for watching
the h3 podcast we love you thanks for
common we will see you next week we wish
in lots of love he's on the love both
the love adventure with the Bachelorette
we're gonna have to meet her you can't
hide her from us forever we got a no
delete that contract right I think the
contract gets ripped up at this point
once she moves here and you guys are in
love they're gonna babies I bet we're
gonna have a bachelor baby the first
ever bachelor baby you're like over
overbearing parents like one of the
babies coming about and the whole
history of the show The Bachelor is
there a bachelor baby like other is no
good for them but I always wanted to be
the first is to live an undead fiance
some tomorrow we have today the preview
it's a preview mandated those guys milk
the [ __ ] out of that show 30-minute
preview and they make it seem like it's
its own show
but then here's what they do that's
crazy there's a very dramatic sounds
like from what they do is that they show
the same 30 minutes on the full show
that that's the next day but there's
just little bits they put in that wasn't
in the preview just Jack you watch it
although you'll have to watch it and can
and you feel like such a loser and get
you every time we still watch it watch
it
I love that show what can I say I
believe in true love that's why I like
90 day fiancé
alright guys thank you for watching have
a fantastic weekend we love you
appreciate you we'll see you next time
alright God blast Papa Busbee Church of
Little Italy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
I get I have like a phobia that once I
say a name wrong I get so embarrassed
that I never want to say it
Rachel Brosnan Brosnahan oh that was
Chrissy Teigen Laurie Laughlin and
Mossimo Julianne Gianelli with Mark Ruby
a did I say your name right you didn't